[Music]
but you're living at home and so are you
working through grad school I am okay so
the expectation is Miss Richie Rich
you're going to pay for us and our bills
and everything or you have the funds to
do so so why not you don't care about
what happens to us or
[Music]
go what up what up this is John with Dr
John delone
show show about your mental health your
emotional health your families your
relationships whatever you got going on
in your life Financial
life man there's a lot of financial
stress and Chaos out there whatever you
got going on in your life my promise is
I'll sit with you and we will figure it
out if you want to be on the show give
me a buzz at 84469
33291 it's 1844 693 3291 or go to John
dooney.com
askk don't forget
we're getting right up on the holidays
here uh man if you order right now right
now you can probably if there's any left
get the questions for humans
Thanksgiving Christmas and um all the
other decks for your holiday season they
have
time yes this show airs the day after
Thanksgiving oh the day after
Thanksgiving the Monday after Monday G
they're gone so those are gone but now
we are all about Christmas decks there
you go Christmas yeah it's we are it's
all Christmas all the time right now
let's go
or happy holidays nope Merry
Christmas uh Xmas
duh my husband gets mad at me if I use
that just got canceled I dude everyone's
I think this Show's long past that I
think we're way I think we're cancel
proof at this point I I wouldn't go
cancel proof there's some things that
you say off air that I was like that
that would end the show yeah for sure
really yeah for sure but I think um yes
we're all I think we're good let's go
out to Colombia South Carolina and talk
to the great Haley what's up
Haley hey guys how's it going we're
partying what about
you I almost partying I haven't
graduated yet but I'm about to excellent
excellent what's
up so due to me about to graduate taking
board exams move out and move on with my
life in
general I'm finding that there are
certain Financial expectations or habits
from my family okay um and response to
me putting up certain boundaries that
are not going so well wait let me back
out a little bit so you're taking boards
what are you taking boards
for um to become a clinical data analyst
wow very cool and then you're still
living at
home yes I did during graduate school to
try to save on cost excellent and that
cost you in your soul right it it it did
really did so um are
you are you first Jen are you the first
one in your family to quote unquote make
it get
out I would technically be the second
second okay but is not common at all but
you're living at home and so are you
working through grad
school I am okay so the expectation is
oh miss Richie Rich going to pay for us
and our bills and
everything or you have the funds to do
so so why not oh that makes it even
worse that makes it a oh you have this
so if you don't do it you're holding out
on us you don't love us you don't care
about what happens to us gosh dude that
that's one of my very very I have very
few triggers that make me just insta
angry that's one of them oh my gosh
somebody's trying to make their life
better and the old world that they come
from just throws every hook they have
into their just bare flesh to hold you
back oh my gosh okay so how can I
help um I've the like I said the
reallocating funds is the easy part for
me um I'm still trying to deal with the
emotional aftermath of saying no to
things or saying that I can't do x y and
z
um I the amount of and know you probably
hear it all the time but the amount of
guilt that weighs on
me
is painful in the sense I start second
guessing and doubting
myself um
of wow okay I I I keep trying not to get
upset when I say these things it would
be really strange if you were able to
say these things and not get
upset if here's
why I want nothing more in the
world than my son and my
daughter to have a more whole healthier
life than
me and that's across a
spectrum I hope that they have a more
grounded spirit life than I did I was
such a chaotic mess I have been I
probably still
am I hope that they don't have the same
demons when it comes to the person they
see in the mirror
physically I hope that financially that
money for them is an opportunity to
serve and help and love and bring joy
and to themselves and to their families
and to their communities and not this
thing that just ravages their soul like
I want their the lives to be better than
what I've got and I've got it pretty
good
and every parent I know wants that it's
the those other
parents and brothers and sisters I've
got brothers and sisters and cousins and
they are rooting for me like you
wouldn't
believe and you have the
opposite you have people that are are
connecting themselves to you so that
they can drag you back so that you can
fund their
desire to not work or their lack of or
their whatever and so what you're
experiencing is not the way it should be
and if it shouldn't be that way your
body should try to get your attention to
help make it right and so if you're able
just to be like oh yeah and then my mom
and dad and then my cousins then my
sister and brother whatever if you're
able to just rattle that off you've
detached from reality in a pretty
significant way so I want to tell you I
think your emotions are right they feel
whole to me
okay you're not
crazy so what is guilt tell me about
this
guilt um this is actually a question I
thought about multiple times and I'm
just now I guess accepting reality of
the situation
um and that being not from the most
affluent background and or
childhood that
that I felt as though I was kind of a
burden um and using resources whether it
be
financially all the upkeeps that it
takes to have a child in the first place
um so I found that I where did that come
from did they tell you that for that did
they tell you
that or did you create that or was it
kind of in the
air it
was I
I not going to put this uh the more
involved I got into family finances from
a very young age the more aware I guess
it became of how much I cost as far as
um activities I wanted to do or be a
part of
or um you know we have to pay for her
books so we can't get X Y and Z and I
just yeah that is so manipulative and
gross it's gross that they did that to
you you're their kid you're you're here
because
of something they did not
you right and all kids want and desire
and seek experiences and want to be with
their friends and want to try things out
it's the parents job to look at reality
finances and to say hey we're not going
to be able to do that we're going to do
this or in this house we're not going to
do that we're going to go do
this it's never okay for a parent to say
yeah cool we'll we'll let you play
soccer and I guess uh I just won't go I
won't do anything fun for the next six
months cuz it's all about you huh
kid and you learn at a really young
age that that burdens some question you
were asking like oh my Dad's life would
be better if I wasn't
here my mom's life would be more joyful
because she would have more resources if
I wasn't around and what you learn to do
I'm guessing is squash the things that
made you happy or that you wanted to
like go
explore whether it was sports or
instruments or friends or going to a
birthday party across town or whatever
the thing
was cuz usually in these situations it
starts out as money but it ends ends up
as I don't want to have to drive you
I've been working all day or you're just
going to sit there on the couch while
I'm off working and you're not going to
do anything to contribute around here
right yes sires that sound
familiar yes sir yeah and then somehow
someway you were born of something
different you had a fire inside of
you you said I'm getting out of
here and this nonsense stops with
me and what they don't tell you in the
Instagram posts and they don't tell you
in grad school which I wish they
would is you don't get off scottf free
it
hurts and when you pull away from those
hooks that people have stuck in your
back and in your skin and your legs it
rips your skin it burns it hurts you
bleed so I guess what I'm trying to tell
you is the guilt yeah man you're your
two parents should be rooting for you in
such a such a they should be your number
one fanatic
cheerleaders they shouldn't be
vampires and so with like pulling away
from that yeah guilt is normal it's
right you're not crazy because you feel
guilty you're not even crazy if you go
out on your own and you get stable and
you cut them off for a
season
as part of forming
boundaries and they've probably told you
you'll never make it without them is
that
true or but
I into terms it's it's more so of I
guess it's a generational thing to have
unspoken of I help to get you where you
are therefore it's like a more so
treated like a give and take transaction
rather than being yeah like you're some
kind of 401k for them
right honestly that pisses me off point
that's what it feels like like hey we
like we've been keeping numbers and
here's how much we've invested in you so
this is what you owe us at 12% return
Hey listen Haley that is absolute Stone
Mad Bull
craap it's
ridiculous and if they were your
financial advisor I would tell you to
fire
them because they're not telling you
truth but this is more complex because
it's Mom and Dad it's
family and I'm going to tell you the
same thing you need to fire them you
need to walk
away do you have another um and I'm not
saying Forever by the way I'm not one of
those guys like you cut TI and never
come at um for whatever reason they've
created the world they've created and
I'm sure if I went back in their
histories they've had a pretty chaotic
life is that
fair that's fair yeah it's not an excuse
but it giv there a context right um
right do you have a group of people that
you've met like in grad school that are
all Haley all the
time I have or I do have friends who um
honestly are the ones who tell me like
this is complete and utter BS and of
course I to absolve myself of guilt
which I had to recognize and don't
absolve it don't absolve it don't abve
soul don't absolve it head right into it
don't run from
guilt guilt is
right it's your body trying to reconcile
all the nonsense and reality it's your
body trying to reconcile hey we're doing
a thing we were told not to do and what
you have to do is hold that thing at
arms length and say hey is this
true because some guilt is right you
know what I mean and some if you if you
just went to your mom and just were
super disrespectful and ugly like I
can't believe you're terrible mom yeah
you should feel guilty cuz that's not
not
cool it's dishonoring to speak to your
mom that way but creating boundaries
that keep your you safe and keep you
whole and allow you to go do this
amazing job and to create this new life
that is going to be free from poverty
and free from making the kids drive the
wagon instead of the adults in the world
Drive the wagon um yeah you get to set
some pretty firm boundaries
there and your mom and dad can gravy
train you all they want they can for and
KU you and you owe us that you don't owe
them anything
Financial zero none unless y'all came up
with some agreement you'll pay back grad
school or something but I have a strong
suspicion that they did not pay for your
grad
school or college now or anything that's
right how much do you owe are you in the
hole after
this um I was at least um well before
the end of college it was covid um so I
was paused at around
80,000 good gosh for undergrad and
beginning of grad um I've what do you
now been making payments during the
pause and down to least 60 good for you
good for you all right here's the deal
I'm just going to make this a
mathematical equation okay okay you are
underwater you have absolutely no
business trying to bail somebody else's
boat get the water out of their boat
because yours is sinking yours is
underwater
too right and this is not about guilt
this is just math you have no business
bailing somebody else out until at least
you're above
water and so if you're working on
practicing building uh practicing
boundaries I want you to start there hey
guys I am $880,000
$60,000 in the hole I'm not sending any
money to anybody other than Sally May
other than to the government to get
these loans taken care of y'all are on
your
own do you still live at
home apparently yes when do you move
out applications where I've submitted
single lease applications those get
taken up from January February what does
that
mean um that means that
they viewed my application and once
someone moves out I'm on a wait list to
basically take their place in in a
campus residence
hall it's the equivalent upper class
living yes okay what about an apartment
often apartments are way cheaper because
you don't have to pay for the board plan
I've also put in applications for
apartments and I want here's my deal on
a wait list for January I want you out
before January I want you out before the
holidays I want you out as soon as
possible if January has to be January
cool but I want you to really quickly
like we're recording this at the very
beginning of November I want you to like
within the week put some very clear
boundaries on the presents you will not
be buying for the adults if you want to
buy something for your nieces and
nephews
fine hey this year guys I'm pay I'm
focused wholly on starting this new
career and getting myself out of 60,000
do in debt every extra Penny I have will
be going towards that so I want everyone
to know I'm not buying a bunch of
presents this year I'm not and when you
do that I want you to just take your
hand and put it on your chest and I want
you to feel that guilt because it's
going to be heavy feel it breathe
through
it until your body lets it run go for a
walk and ask yourself why you're walking
because I know that you're brilliant
hey is this guilt right is it my job to
make sure my the adults in my life have
a thing Christmas no it's not have I
worked really hard and I'm blessed to
make a good salary yeah and right now
that salary goes to paying off the
investment the debts I took out on
myself not making sure other people have
momentary glips
of hooray and by the way their 401K
investment in you is twofold number one
it's Financial
you owe us no you freaking
don't number two it's also um cultural
they are going to walk around with their
chest puffed out look what we did for
our
baby they didn't do anything you did in
fact you've been propping them up for a
long long
time a long time they say that poverty
is a mindset it's not a financial number
and this is one of the ways it traps
you because here's what's going to
happen if you don't if you don't make a
clean break now what you're going to end
up doing is cosigning on a car loan
because one of their cars is going to
bust or you're going to cosign on a loan
to fix the air conditioner the heater
because it's going to break you're still
going to be 60,000 in the hole and then
you're going to need to come up with the
money for the first and last months
whatever and that's going to put you a
little bit deeper and you're going to
end up with a job paying 100,000 bucks
and you're going to owe
$125,000
instantly and you will then
self-perpetuate this same crisis the
difference is you're going to do what I
did which was I wasn't never in poverty
but we did not have a lot growing up we
had very very little in fact it's a
shock to our friends and neighbors how
little we
had
but when I went and got my fancy degree
I spent like crazy crazy and I ended up
digging a bigger hole than my family
could have ever my parents could have
ever dug CU they didn't have the access
to that kind of
money but the more the more sour you
make sometimes and the higher your um
degree stature the more the banks will
just willy-nilly loan you and I ended up
in a bigger
hole so why' I tell you all that break
free choose freedom and I'm glad you've
got some friends I want you to reach out
to them I also want you to reach out to
the College Counseling Center and say
hey I'm getting ready to to make some
pretty significant changes in my life I
want to practice some of this y all walk
alongside me you don't need to go to a
Counseling Center because you're
deficient or broken or have some sort of
disorder I want you to go use the
counseling resources at the school that
you pay for by the way um they're baked
into your your tuition and fees I want
you to go and practice some of these
conversations practice telling your mom
and dad hey no more money this this
Christmas um January I'm out December
15th I'm moving out I love you guys but
it's time for me to to do it on my
own and by the way you're not doing it
on your own you're inviting friends
you're going to bring that Community
super close weekly dinners weekly
laundry parties weekly whatever study
parties your place your place your
place this is building something
completely new I'm proud of you Haley
and don't discount the hurt this will
hurt along the way and I think that her
is
right you're you're making a whole new
family treat I'm proud of you we'll be
right
back hey deloney here and it's pumpkin
spice latte season just kidding that's
disgusting but it is fall it's a little
cooler the sun's going down earlier and
God help us daylight savings time is
ending or starting or whatever the time
is the time is changing again and it can
be exhausting to adjust to everything
all the time so make sure you're moving
your body every day getting sunlight in
the morning and in the evening and
getting 7 to9 hours of sleep each night
I can't stress enough how important this
is sleep is the Cornerstone to physical
and mental and emotional health and for
me great sleep starts with an amazing
mattress that's why I love dreamcloud
and why my family sleeps on dreamcloud
and right now dreamcloud is running an
awesome offer 40% off all mattresses
plus an additional $50 in savings
exclusively for our listeners go to
dreamcloud sleep.com and enter promo
code John deloney that's dreamcloud
sleep.com with code John deloney for 40%
off all mattresses and an extra $50 in
savings all right let's go out to yip
Salan Michigan and talk to chase what's
up
Chase not much just living the dream how
about yourself do y' dream in Yip Salan
yes sir excellent we all dream and Yip
salant what's up
dude oh well first off just big thank
you I appreciate all that you and your
team do you guys are a big blessing to
so many people and it's a privilege to
be on the show so I appreciate it I do
most of the work the team kind of just
that's that's not true they all look at
me like oh really we can turn this off
right
now yeah you win as a team right it's 90
well I lose by myself they yeah we all
win as a team um it's about 98% them 2%
me for sure so what's up
dude um so the question I want to bring
to you is uh so how can I rebuild
healthy habits and routines that I
fumbled since covid started and have
lacked the motivation to return to tell
me about it so as as a bit of backstory
so in 2019 I started grad school and
when Co lockdown happened obviously I
was in the middle of my second semester
oh jeez and with that yeah with with
everything moving online like I lost the
intentional it I had with like healthy
eating and with exercise and it resulted
in me gaining 60 pounds and I've still
kind of had a tough time uh returning to
to some of those healthy habits like um
and even with even my my career being uh
online I I wake up five minutes before
my day at work starts and so like it's a
it's I'm still kind of on this this
rebuilding path here but like and and as
another thing on top of that my wife
wife and I had a baby uh who's five
months old now and uh she's the LI of my
life couldn't be happier but also you
know with a baby that also makes it a
little bit more difficult to feel like I
can break away and uh and do things like
exercise um and it's it's really
important to me that I want to be a good
example of healthy decisions and healthy
habits to my baby and to all the others
that we have and so like I it's it's
important to me to want to rebuild some
of those habits that I lost because I
I've been struggling with the motivation
to get back on the back uh get back on
the horse awesome man well I man dude
thanks for the call and I'm proud of you
for catching this right and you're doing
what most people don't do is like the
smoke is kind of clearing this is your
new life you work from home um the last
few years have been chaotic you've been
married you have a kid so one of these
years was your wife being pregnant
you'll dreaming and then you working and
all that so um but I'm I'm proud of you
dude for going up to the top of the hill
and looking over the clouds and the
smoke and going okay I get to decide
what happens next MH okay thank you um
that's tough and I know it's like oh
dude bro and then David Goggins is like
who's gonna carry the boats and you're
like I dude I what what like so I'm
proud of you right um I want to talk
through a few things and kind of dig in
a little bit is that okay for sure and
I'll give I'll give you some tactical
things thing thing number
one hard question
MH why don't you like
chase that is a hard question but but
you know the answer why don't you like
Chase I think that
it's like I I hold on I've strugg hold
on you don't like Chase
why you're good at not answering that
question because you're very very kind
and you're very
smart why don't you like Chase
I don't like that chase is overweight
and that he's not doing enough to to
correct that issue okay what's beneath
that
um I would say like
some Fame I guess that um I can't seem
to keep a regular exercise routine that
I can't you know put my foot down when
it comes to the things that I eat and um
to kind of take the rein on those
decisions I that's something that I
struggle with and I think that builds
some shame yeah but what's what about
the shame beneath that here here's the
here's the signal you gave me that
there's something else I think those
things are important I've experienced
both of those myself and I think those
are signals those are lights on the
dashboard of a more challenging
issue you are sleeping your light Life
Away mhm distracting you're avoiding
your own
life why are you building a life why
have you inadvertently unintentionally
built a life where Chase can avoid
chase you sleep right up until the
moment that you got to work you work
from home all the way up until you get
done with that you love that little baby
until she has to go back to Mom because
five month old babies don't really give
a crap out their dad except they kind of
do nervous system wise but not in
reality
and then you either have a beer or you
sit on the and you and your wife eat
together and that's your romantic time
so of course your body brings you back
that's the only connection point you
have with your wife anymore is meals and
then you either watch a TV show or you
just go to
bed
Fair that's fair so you've built a life
and this isn't on purpose your body in
an effort to protect you has built a
life where you don't have to deal with
Chase that's why underneath the weight
gain underneath the lack of motivation
underneath the lack of
discipline there's this ticker tape
running under the story of your life
under the movie of your life that says
Chase kind of sucks what is
that I'm not sure like I feel
like I feel like it could be like
the maybe the the hopes and dreams that
I have for myself in terms of personal
development that I'm not attaining I
don't know like
um cuz like we're we're relatively new
to this area we're nowhere near family
and um and so like it's it's tough to
build friends and with and since I'm not
hanging out with a lot of people and my
wife works sometimes and stuff and so
I'm like I feel stuck at home and what's
a different word for
that what's a a word that men don't say
out loud
I'll say it sounds like you're lonely
man are you are you doing well
financially is this was this a good move
for
you yeah I mean we're we're very blessed
financially we just became debt free
last month so financially we're we're
doing great was there a sense that when
I made X dollars and I'm got job y that
I would feel a certain way and it's
Dawning on you after grad school after
you're starting this work from home
job that you went with
you I think that like the the
discrepancy and like the mental picture
is is socially and and tiing back to
that loneliness you mentioned I guess
cuz like working from home you know you
don't build many in-person relationships
you don't have like a a built-in kind of
friend Network like at work and then I
get home and you know I'm with the two
people in my life who I love the most
but also like I just I don't have
anybody else to like just pick up and
say hey let's let's go do X activity
together or something like that like and
so I I can see where that loneliness
ties into that too cool all right so
here's what we're going to do we are
going to stop waiting on
motivation here's the the weird lie
about
motivation that well I'll just I'll just
reverse engineer it you do a bunch of
stuff over a period of time that you
don't like
doing and then you see some results from
it and then you begin to feel a
different way you been to feel good and
then your body says let's do more of
that and so strangely we often wait for
motivation to do a thing we wait for
motivation to change our sex life we
wait for motivation to be nicer to our
wife or to be a better wife to our
husband like I'm going to you know when
he starts doing this then I'm going to
start doing instead of just hammer it
making it a discipline issue versus a
motivation motivation issue the
motivation
comes it always does but it wains it
goes up and it goes down and what so
I've had to learn the hard way
motivation gets zero votes in my life
none zero I love it when it shows up
because it makes what I'm trying to do
easier whether I'm writing or whether
I'm trying to be a better husband or I'm
plugging in with my kids um or trying to
take care of my health but most of the
time it doesn't show up most of the time
it just annoying right so it gets
literally zero votes in my
life the second thing is you probably
heard me say this on the show a lot from
a personal conversation I had with Sal
de Stefano from mind
pump you cannot shame or hate your body
into better
shape he told me this privately and it
was so profound for me after second PhD
I had all this psychology all this
whatever and I'd sat with a number of
hurting people and no one had ever
communicated this in the way that he did
he said if you go to the gym or try to
not eat a piece of cake one
time because you think I'm fat and gross
and I don't want to be fat and
gross you will always run out of
steam because you can't shame or hate
your way into anything productive period
MH he said if you flip it around and
wake up every day and practice
saying I love myself enough to be a good
husband and a good dad and I love myself
enough that I get one
hour I'm so lucky that I get to get up
today that I was on the wakeup roll
cosmically I'm so lucky that that little
girl gets to gets got me as a dad I get
an
hour I get to invest an hour in me cuz
I'm wor that and he said if you flip
that around and you make it a
stewardship issue versus a not being so
disgusting issue dude you can go
forever okay if you if you if you invest
money if you save
money and you hate every second of
saving you're not going to save very
long if you save money with the intent
of your grandkids
smiling through their tears after your
funeral when they see the inher itance D
that's a whole other ball game
right yeah it's just a different way to
look at it here's a third thing you are
going to have to do the opposite of what
most people do the greatest gift you can
give your daughter right now is not 247
365 access to her dad the greatest gift
you can give your daughter is you go
make some
friends the greatest gift you can give
your daughter is to go to the gym and
normally I tell people to get a gym at
their house I think you need the
opposite I think you need to go
somewhere and probably start going to a
couple of
classes okay and I'm not even into
classes I think this is just an easy way
for you to to be accountable for a
season and you're going to show up and
you're going to start seeing some of the
same faces and I want you to go be weird
because part of you or a big part of you
is going to want to hide I'm 60 pounds
overweight I'm an embarrassment I jiggle
when I jump I don't look right you see
what I'm saying but you're not going to
do that you're going to go hey what's up
man my name's
Chase and they're going to go awesome
good to see you dude you are kicking
button here you are too man
sweet and you're just going to go be
weird I wish there was another way to do
it dude there just
not but you've got to make decisions to
be away from your home instead of always
there okay does that make sense yes sir
and I hate that for you and don't if you
don't want take classes and you school
if weights that's that's
fine uh another thing you can do is just
put your daughter in a stroller and take
her for walks around the neighborhood
during breaks at
work do you ever do
that yeah and and especially on days
where my wife works she's a nurse and
she works like from afternoon to late at
night and so I'll usually take her on
walks uh usually the days that she works
and then I kind of I I kind of lose that
when she's at home cuz we're all
together and things get distracting but
yeah I I'm intentional about walks when
my wife word let's change that language
you allow things to get distracting mhm
but when your wife gets home y'all can
all three go for a walk and I know it
because we I did it even when I was
exhausted me and my wife and my son me
and my wife and my
daughter that's not the same as as a
weightlifting ex like series season but
it's something and it kind of brings you
and your wife back together instead of
just in front of the TV most couples
spend most of their together time in
front of a television
set right and that's not real intimacy
it's just proximal um here's what I'm
going to do I'm G hook you up with a
couple things um number one um I'm going
to hook you up with
the um weight loss app that I use my
friend Dr Lane Norton it's the best one
in the business it's called carbon it's
what I use every single day of my life
okay uh H Andy hberman uses it like it's
what people use it's incredible and I'm
going to give it to you for a year okay
um hang on the line here and we're going
to get you set up the other thing I'm
going to give you is my friends at mind
pump will give you any of their workouts
that you would like any of them again
their workouts that I use I give to my
personal friends okay and you can go
through it and pick it and I think it
would be excellent excellent excellent
the third thing is I want you do you
have
Instagram no sir okay I can't believe
I'm recommending this but I want you
actually don't do it don't do it but I
want you to go on YouTube and I want you
to follow my friend Jordan scatt s y a
TT he makes funny videos and he does
swear a lot so you're gonna have to just
shake that off probably don't watch it
in front of your kid but he is a a great
human being B one of the most
knowledgeable guys in the industry and
he has made some
videos dude and I I just hav privileged
to rub shoulders with some of the
smartest guys in the industry who I have
their personal cell number I call them
and they walk me through things and he
has made some videos that is just like a
light bulb for
me okay and I want you to follow Jordan
s y a TT those three that gang the Mind
pump guys Dr Norton and Jordan
SC will give you the tools both on a
daily basis with Jordan's videos the
actual tools for Dr Norton's carbon app
and the M pump guys and and list I get I
have no Financial affiliation with these
dudes I don't get one penny from
anything I'm just telling you this is
what I use in my
house as a guy who struggled with my
weight struggled with shame struggled
with
um even knowing if I'm hungry or not but
my body just eats when I get stressed to
seeing a baby a little baby that I love
more than life itself but I don't know
what I'm doing and I get
scared right that shame my wife seems to
just know how to do all this stuff and I
don't know how to do any of it and so I
just hide except you don't have an
office to go to you have another room
which makes it weird
right right well and thank you that's
all very generous I appreciate that well
here's the deal um I want you the only
thing I ask in return is in 30 days I
want you to have actually used this
stuff and in 30 days I want you write me
back and let me know where you
are okay and the scale is just a part of
that the scale is just going to be
reflective of it's the dashboard for or
Chase has
decided he's worth living a better
life he's worth feeling really good he's
worth sleeping really good he's worth
not snoring anymore he's worth modeling
in front of his
kids and by the way if you don't want to
go if you'd rather work out at home and
model that for your kid
awesome I personally think the five
months to a year I think you're good
going for six months to a gym meeting
new people seeing how things go even if
you find a trustworthy personal trainer
that's going to show up that you're
going to have to pay for I think that's
worth it if it's one of if it's a
personal trainer clown and the mind pump
guys have some good things you can
Google about what's a good train or not
there's clowns out there but there's
clowns every in every industry also some
really amazing folks but give yourself
the accountability but go out and make
Community invite people from your local
church invite people from the gym invite
you have your wife invite some of her
nursing friends and their husbands over
go be intentionally weird this is me
telling you to stop smoking except I'm
going to tell you stop doing loneliness
stop being
alone and I wish there was an easy path
forward there just not just got to go
it's hard and you got to go be
weird but meta lesson people listening
to this don't wait for motivation it
will not show up it won't show up or it
might like a like a bolt of lightning
and then it goes
away lean on discipline lean on a choice
that I'm going to tell myself the truth
cuz I am
trustworthy and I'm going to get up
every day and make a choice to to move
my body I'm going to get up every day
and make a choice to plug in with my
wife and say how can I love you today
I'm going to wake up every day and hold
that baby's face and just look directly
into its eyes I'm going to wake up every
day and decide I'm going to eat
right make those choices no wait on
motivation you got this Chase thanks for
your call we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone what in the world
is going on listen this is that time of
year Family Travel everyone telling you
what to do the end of the year fiscal
season money politics all of it and all
of it's happening in the dark because
the sun goes down and it doesn't seem to
want to come up Seasonal effective
disorder is real so you put Darkness on
top of all of it and wow it gets dark at
4:30 where I live and I'm ready for bed
at 5:45 in the evening things aren't as
fun sometimes even my food tastes
different but now I know I got to take
care of my body I got to get outside
even when it's dark outside or even when
it's early in the morning I got to move
my body I got to put bright lights in my
eyes and I have to intentionally connect
with people and sometimes intentionally
connecting with people is about friends
and other times intentionally connecting
with people is with therapy therapy can
be a bright spot in the chaos at the end
of the year even when the Sun goes down
too soon something to help you feel
positive and grounded and give you tools
to manage all this madness when nothing
else will so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give betterhelp a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online and it can fit into any
schedule you have just fill out a short
questionnaire you're going to get
matched with the licensed therapist and
you can switch therapist at any time for
no charge find your bright spot in the
chaos find some peace When Everything
feels like it's spinning out of control
with my friends at betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com delone today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com delone you're worth
it all right let's go out to Karina in
Columbus Ohio what's up
Karina hello
hello what's up how are you um I'm great
thank you for uh talking to me I really
appreciate it of course thanks for
calling what's up um I have lost a lot
of weight this year how much and about
65 pounds
whoa well I still have a fair amount to
lose but I'm uhh we're not blown by that
yeah so
dude that's my
daughter yeah and I carry my daughter
around through New York City a few weeks
ago and she got very very heavy yeah
you've lost my child dude
congratulations that's amazing how have
you done it uh I am uh taking shots okay
and and I I've started to move a little
bit more good for you I'm proud of you
what's your goal how far how far do you
want to go
I I really need to lose at least 100
pounds okay 100 pounds total or 100 more
just 100 total and really according to
the charts it should be 150 but if I can
get 100 off it's you know it's
lifechanging really for me I'm telling
you 65 is lifechanging you got 35 to go
you'll be there in no time
congratulations I'm so proud of you when
you add movement to this obviously with
your doctor when you add movement to
this oh it's GNA Exel dude I'm so proud
of you it's awesome all right so what's
up
well I'm concerned because I can't see
it okay I've um and I'm worried if I
can't figure out how to see the weight
loss then I'm going to gain the weight
back because that's my my hu my biggest
fear is that I gain the weight back okay
so when you say you can't see it is it
objective or is it um body
dysmorphic I'm not sure yeah I said that
as dorky as I could have so objective
like when you see people you haven't
seen in a few weeks or you see your
doctor are they just like oh my gosh and
you're just like y are crazy
or um did you have so much to lose that
65 PBS is not even halfway to the like
you see what I'm saying like you have a
long long way to go it really took 40
pounds or so for people start to see and
like at the 50 pound Mark now people are
saying you know they're they're noticing
okay
but I've once I started looking at this
I've noticed like I have I don't look at
myself in the mirror I Look to make sure
I'm clean or I don't have wrinkles but I
have no full body mirrors in my house I
don't look at me because I don't like
how I look I guess there you go and like
if I go try clothes on the other day I
need new clothes I had everything from
an extra large to a 4X because I hadn't
I couldn't look at the clothes and see
that fits my body
where did you end up at did you end up
with uh
downsizes yeah of course you did because
you lost 65 pounds you lost my
child right but I hold up a Forex and
I'm like well maybe that fits well yeah
you know and I'm just really really
afraid I'll gain the weight back because
it's I'm taking the shots which help
sure but it's hard work yeah it is all
right so here here's what I think here's
what I think tell me if I'm crazy can
can we just speak like just just direct
friend to friend brother to sister yes
all right yes I
think you can see
it I think you thought it would feel
differently H I think you thought losing
65 PBS well on your way to a
100 which is
unbelievable It's amazing And if your
doctor has said hey 150 would be great
my 13-year-old son is humongous he's
140 I could carry him on my back not
very
far so the thought of losing the
entirety of my 13-year-old my eighth
grade son who by all metrics is
humongous that's amazing
and it is removing a barrier between you
in the
world and in some way that barrier kept
you safe or or kept you hidden or kept
you some space between you and the
world and there's this there's a lie
that says when we lose that we're
suddenly gonna if we get a million
dollars suddenly we're gonna if I get
that car suddenly we're gonna if I lose
this weight suddenly I'm goingon
to and you go to the mirror and you look
just at your face because you don't have
a full body mirror and you thought it
would feel different what do you
think well I do agree I I feel invisible
A lot of the time because of my weight
you know you want to be invisible that's
right and there's a certain level of
comfort in that of course yeah and that
and that Comfort kills you right yeah
yeah but
um yeah I guess I I thought I would be
happier that's it right there you know I
I
thought I mean I guess happier maybe why
why
what happened to Karina that Karina
thinks she's just a piece of
crap I think you know everything goes
back to when you're young you know I had
I came from a fairly religious family
and I ended up getting pregnant at 15
and I had my son okay and I did not get
married and I did not give him away and
I did not have an abortion did that cost
you
everything pretty much yeah most of my
family disowned me yeah so you know what
you figured out at 15 that love was for
the people who were closest to you love
for your tribe love for your family was
contingent yeah and I figed out I was
not going to be loved and that's pretty
much carried through my entire adult
life well once you once once you in your
15-year-old mind thought that and you
had some pretty compelling
evidence you went looking for that
everywhere right
every single place you could find
proofed that you weren't worth being
loved you went and found
it this is true and I don't we don't
trust 15y olds to
drive right because they're crazy
they're not allowed to buy beer or guns
or go to the milit right because they're
and your 15-year-old also got a really
clear glimpse of some harsh
reality you are only lovable if you do
the right
otherwise Love's
off right and that wasn't that wasn't
theory for you that was
real and it made me very angry for a
very long time you should
be but um you should be you know the
number of parents I've sat with when
their kid gets pregnant in
colleges and they come to me and they
say what do I do what do I
say and I ask him you remember when you
found out you were pregnant and you had
a baby coming and you remember holding
that baby the first time and they always
smile and I say don't take that from
that kid 15's really young that's hard
15's hard 18 19 20 it's a little bit
different but 15 is
tough yeah but I've had Parents call me
and say hey we went with this isn't the
picture we had for you but we're about
to have a
baby and so they Circle the wagon even
even tighter the wagon of Love they
Circle that connection even
Tighter and you didn't have that at 15
you were all by
yourself it was um it was not an easy
time no but no and how old are you now
57 okay
57 so for 42 years you've been carrying
this
around
yeah when are you going to let
Karina that 15-year-old Karina finally
drop her shoulders and go be
15 because she's still fighting for you
she's still hating for you she's still
angry for you she still doesn't look
beautiful to you she still remembers all
the
comments when are you going to let her
go I don't know because my I've tried to
work on my internal messaging to
myself
and it's still fairly negative
yeah and I'm I I don't know how to fix
that per here's what we're going to do
we are going to
learn to be objective about feelings and
this is a crappy awful hard thing to do
okay but I promise you and I promise
because I've experienced it myself
personally you can change this
okay a unless your doctor says I'm wrong
right your doctor would know like
pathologies your doctor would know some
mental health challenges your doctor
would know this kind of stuff more than
me but I would recommend you getting a
mirror one of those $10 mirrors that's
full
length because here's what you're doing
you're avoiding you every
day and I want you to head directly into
that
discomfort because Karina is worth being
L does Karina have a lot of weight to
lose and some challenges you're dang
right she does and I'm not one of these
like body positivity like you're that's
not true and Karina's worth being
loved and Karina's worth taking care of
herself right and clearly you know this
because you've made
incredible inspirational progress in
change but you can't tell me I don't see
it and at the same time avoid every
mirror that you come
across there's going to be some recal
calibration you pick up a 4X and you're
like oh I think this is it and then
suddenly you end up in a 1X and you're
like whoa that's
normal that's like me getting in my old
farm truck and then getting in like a
newer car like I you know hit the gas
too fast and I hit the brake too hard
like I got to adjust to this new thing
right this new vehicle I'm in that's
okay that's part of it but I want you to
get a journal and I want you to keep
every time you think the words I'm gross
or I'm not making any
progress or I'm not
happy I want you to write those things
down and I want you to demand evidence
from
them because objectively what you're
telling me they're not
true or if you're not happy ask yourself
what could I do right now to increase
some of the some of the joy in my
life go for a walk go watch a sunset
call my
kid go hang out call my girlfriends go
hang out what would that
be I ask you Karina what brings you
Joy um really you say you know I talk to
my son I talk to my friends I'm I'm very
fortunate I have friendships that are 30
40 years
amazing um do they know do they truly
know that
Karina just is grossed out by
Karina they don't know that it's time to
bring no it's time to bring him in bring
him in yeah bring him in and I want you
to tell him this yall know I've lost a
bunch of weight and I'm I've got another
100 lb to go I'm going for another 90
lbs to
go but that's secondary
too I've got to reckon with and begin to
become friends with Karina again I'm
going to stop living a life where I
avoid
myself will you guys walk alongside me
as I changed my internal dialogue to
myself and I I guarantee you they will
God I would be in honor if one of my
friends asked me to do
that oh they absolutely would I I'm very
blessed with some amazing friends that
is a like um in a strange way I'm asking
you to get a full length mirror and look
at yourself and make and put your hand
on your chest when you start to feel
that or that ug or
whatever I've lost 65
lbs I'm going to have five more down in
the next two weeks I'm going to whatever
whatever pace you're
on I want you to feel that objective
this this isn't working it's I'm not
doing anything is that true no
objectively it's false it's not true and
similarly I want you to telling your
friends over a regular cup of coffee
like Hey we're going to get together
once a week and if they're not in the
same Community we're going to do a zoom
call once a week I want you to hold up a
mirror relationally
emotionally hey guys I lost another
three pounds this week and I feel
disgusting
I want you just say those words out loud
to the people who love you and your
friends because you might not trust
Karina but you trust them do you yes
okay so for a season we're going to
start Outsourcing some of the truth
because we can't see it that's okay
we're recalibrating the whole system
kind of like when I get my car and I
change the tires on it and I put some
tough guy tires for hunting it felt like
my car was falling apart and one of my
buddies was like no this is how this
goes I had to Outsource that I didn't
know I just felt like the whole car was
falling apart because these tires were
big and stiff and he was like no no this
is exactly where you're supposed to be
it's
great we're gonna Outsource that for a
bit do you believe me when I tell you
I'm so freaking proud of you yes okay
are you like can we like can you just
drop your shoulders and say 65 pounds is
pretty amazing you know I I was doing
pretty good I was pretty happy with it
and then I had a conversation actually
with my boss and she has some very
strong opinions about people doing what
I'm doing but it's just
lazy and I hold on hold on hold on
dude yeah all right so here's a cool
thing that just
happened your boss opted
out yeah your boss doesn't get a vote
and remember that 15-year-old girl who
was looking for proof that she wasn't
lovable
and you've been looking for 42
years you in your head have this tiny
little narrative that's like you
shouldn't need to go to the
doctor you shouldn't need medicine you
shouldn't need shots you should just be
able to control
this yeah okay and your body is looking
desperately for somebody to validate
that you're a loser and you found
one and I want you to write that down
cuz that's a objectively
false it's not
true Karina I've got two phds I do this
for a living sitting with hurting people
and I had to reach out and get
professional
help
okay yeah I don't have one ounce of
Shame you know why because I couldn't do
it by myself
period I couldn't do it by myself cool
so you know what your boss did she oped
it
out oh you think I'm lazy
cool I'll never ever have this
conversation with you
again I want you to write it down I am
lazy for going to the doctor to get
support and help for
um my obesity
challenges is that true objectively no
it's not it's not it's not
true look around if we could all just
snap our fingers and just diet and
exercise we wouldn't have the crisis we
have it's a big
deal I'm so proud of you for doing what
you need to do and you know there's
going to be stages there's going to be a
season as you mentioned like now I'm
just slowly getting into movement
great my guess is you're going to
accelerate things in a profound way and
you're going to begin to feel
differently because right now a lot of
this has just been thoughts and thoughts
and thoughts and thoughts and thoughts
and changing eating habits and shots and
now you're going to move into more body
transformation great
amazing slow and
steady there is a point Karina when you
have to stop thinking getting all the
thoughts in the right order you have to
start doing you've done step one you've
started working on step two and now now
you're inching into step
three just keep taking steps inch by
inch by inch and I want you to let that
15-year-old girl go what happened to her
was wrong she was absolutely left on her
own in a blizzard with a baby and that
was
wrong
and that's not
everybody not everybody leaves a
15-year-old in the cold holding a baby
in fact most
don't so I want you to stop looking for
somebody to tell you what you're doing
is wrong somebody to tell you that
you're not enough and instead I want you
to get with your friends who love you
and to begin looking for people who see
you for who you are see how hard you're
working and who will cheer you on we're
done validating the bull crap stories
that were not
enough we're now validating the stories
that say wow look how hard your working
keep going Karina I'm so proud of you
we'll be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at johal.com
all r as you wrap up today's show this
the song that Kelly had in her Walkman
during prom on repeat in the
corner it's by Eric Carmen song's
called all by myself it goes like this
when I was young I never needed anyone
and making love was just for fun was it
was it those days are gone living alone
I think of all the friends I've known
but when I dial the telephone nobody's
home okay Telly in the corner right next
to the disco
ball big poofy dress on her
shoulders
[Music]
oh not really she was in the middle
dancing the New Kids on the Block just
letting that freak flag fly
baby H if there was a video recording of
kellot
prom I promise you we would show it love
you guys
bye